man kann eine dramatische sehen dann
spielen wir sind hinter mir diejenigen
die es geschafft haben tagelang hatte
warten aber nur wenige kilometer vom
meer entfernt haben 10.000 menschen und
auf diesem flughafen zu kommen aber wir
sagen wir können nicht allen helfen die
etappe wegen verschiedene bild erschien
ausspielen aus dänemark aus katar auf
verschiedenen ländern
am dienstagmorgen landet bild vize paul
ronzheimer mit einer militärmaschine aus
katar am flughafen in kabul für bild
live berichtet er den ganzen tag über
die dramatische lage so und jetzt haben
wir es geschafft meine damen und herren
wir können live nach kabul schalten per
telefon sind wir mit paul ronzheimer
unserem bild reporter verbunden der vor
wenigen minuten in kabul gelandet ist in
der hölle der taliban das kann man so
sagen paul was sind deine ersten
eindrücke
ich bin vor wenig licht und hier in
karow im lande mit einem flugzeug aus
katar habe dann aber die verwaschene
vier flüchtlinge abholt und das bei mir
sieht der beherzt verbrechens neben dass
ich weg die vollzugs gefällt dieser
flugzeuges gekommen wie er hinter frauen
auf dem militärischen teil aber das
dramatische thomas s der proben noch
laufen stehen wir nicht digital sondern
wenige kilometer entfernt die
20.000 die versuchen hier reinkommen und
wieder vergessen dass sie es nicht
schaffen werden und erst dann habe ich
schwach bleiben wird
das sind dramatische eindrücke die du da
gleich am anfang bekommen hast hast du
eine gelegenheit gehabt mit den truppen
zu sprechen die den militärischen teil
kontrollieren kannst du irgendwas
darüber sagen ob es irgendeine kontrolle
noch gibt
ich halte den die amerikaner
kontrollieren die menschen rein gekommen
hier herrscht ordnung aber deshalb die
menschen versuchen sozusagen ins herz
check points über wissen wenig von dem
moment an auch ganz sehen kannst doch
nicht ist es daher ist das haus und die
amerikaner haben wir ganz oft gesagt wir
werden ihr nicht alle mit dem volk das
er gar nicht schaffen ist bereitet sich
bereits auf den akten vor das hört
beiden hat ja gesagt zum 31 doch sein
was wolle nicht verlängern und das ist
auch mein eindruck den ich hier gewinne
was wir die soldaten erzählen die sagen
dass sie hier wer oder weniger sofort
abbrechen und das ist erst der lauter
wird eine massive die zeit staaten wird
zwar von der suite aus erfurt die wehre
und flüchtlinge aufnehmen wird ist hier
vor mir direkt vor mir hat wird ihr kind
auf dem arm das
soll doch noch abschied fotos aus ihrem
heimatland bevor sich das eine lange
zeit und wirklich für immer ihr land
verlassen wird aus panik vor dem fahrrad
und jetzt eben selbst amerikaner
verteidigt natürlich auf die front ist
er ja eine maschine von katar erfolgt in
der ich gedacht jetzt wird auf diese
zeit günstige aufnehmen das ist hier wie
man kaum beschreiben fans wobei du warst
ja schon wirklich sehr sehr häufig in
afghanistan du erlebst das land jetzt in
einem extremen ausnahmezustand war das
jemals vor so wie es du es jetzt
beschreibst
absolute panik kann man sagen und auch
von allen und auch immer möglich
moldawischen sich die fast
wahrscheinlich enttäuscht dass wir
gerade gelandet ist aber als ich sagen
ihr müsst jetzt doch alle sofort sofort
raus aber
der als wichtig jetzt zu berichten
erklärte vollmer r geht ist nicht so oft
werden aus
der von der internationalen gemeinschaft
wir wollen wir überhaupt kein vergleich
damals nicht sein abschied mit einer
analyse maschine aus istanbul geist ganz
normal ausgestiegen als hafen vorgezeigt
und jetzt lassen wir nur noch mehr
maschinen auf deutsch gibt keine
normalität werden und es gibt auch keine
normalität
und deshalb freunde einzelne sie sollen
vorschläge die berichte die situation
dort noch bezahlt jetzt also im
stadtteil kilometer direkt her ist dass
er stark ist sauberer auf die
versteckten selbst die jetzt immer noch
nicht was sie dort eigentlich soll das
vorhaben ob die sie verfolgt werden oder
aber oft die tatsächlich sollen deutsche
spitzen indirekt gekommen das sind aber
zu glauben diesen abstieg wieder auf der
pressekonferenz passiert ja glauben sie
denjenigen kein wort als sie sozusagen
das dort erlebt haben das kommt
weil wenn man seine worte so hört dann
bekommt man gänsehaut was würdest du
denn jetzt von unserer kanzlerin angela
merkel wünschen für afghanistan und für
die menschen dort vor ort
ich bin gesund auch wenn es
unrealistisch ist das
was ihr landet und ist dass selbst
anschauen sollte das ist es wert ist es
weil es zusätzliche arbeit wäre
sagt dafür sein würde aber wenn
unsere polizei ist in die augen schauen
können da frau dieses oft das glück dass
oft und dass sie tatsächlich auf firmen
aus ihr platz aber dann doch wenige
verbessert werden der fall der hansa
fans nicht weiter kommt und er dem kate
steht obwohl sie nicht durchgelassen
werden und die frage nicht recht
entlassen werden
aber die sich dass ihre relativ die usa
und auch deutschland haben angekündigt
das jetzt nicht als wenig auf dem
wertvoll für uns gearbeitet haben und
das empfinde ich als große schande dass
wir nie verzichten kopf gehalten haben
am ende
entsteht und nicht auf die zu haben für
uns weil wir recht nur hier
weil du stehst wir sehen das foto gerade
vor einer maschine aus katar einer
militärmaschine mit der duh
hereingeflogen bist das ist eine
maschine mit der vor wenigen tagen die
taliban aus katar von dem sie
unterstützt worden sind von dem emirat
hereingeflogen sind was war das für ein
gefühl für dich in einer dieser
maschinen zu sitzen in der kurz zuvor
noch die terroristen ins land geflogen
wurden
und das sagt komm hier berichten von vor
ort es gibt keine liebe mehr die
privaten mit bis 1000 privaten sich
einkauft also fast die einzige chance
für mich davor hatten und dort die
chance zu nutzen mit dieser airline 30
gegen und ich muss sagen dass die
regierung von katar sei ein exzellenter
auf dem absatz fast zumindest
vorstellen
kannst du uns hören ich kann euch ja ich
bin immer noch hier am airfield auf dem
militärgelände
das kommt von den amerikanern und jetzt
versucht man sowohl ich als auch andere
internationale journalisten ihr von dem
verfehlt ich wäre man will uns unter
druck setzen da unten so eine maschine
zurück nach vorn zu bringen wie sonst
auch nicht erlaubt das gelände zu
verlassen richtung kabul was wir
vorhatten wir wollen natürlich auch aus
der stadt berichtet offenbar und das
erhalten des betrages wenn man hier so
gar nichts von uns
das wurde uns gerade vom us militär
mitgeteilt als vier sterne genannt er
habe die entscheidung getroffen dass
alle journalisten
darunter hier zum beispiel auf 4 und
andere und schreiben dazu alle
diese herbst neben diesen flughafen
verlassen das erste was wir uns noch
heute habe es zurück nach los schicken
und dann wird uns nicht erlauben in die
stadt steht das ist eine klare
behinderung der freien presse in einer
trefferliste
hübsch auf tipps auf soll soviel
dramatische viel passieren das ist ein
unglaublicher eingriff in die
pressefreiheit gibt es irgendeine chance
das noch zu vermeiden
natürlich dieser er fiel unter kontrolle
der amerikaner als sie versucht jetzt
alles um das zu verhindern denn unser
start war natürlich von hier auf einem
sicheren wege sobald man versichert
sprechen kann
zurückzukommen nach kabul wo wir letzte
woche aufgerichtet haben also kurz vor
dem fall aber auch damen immer nicht
möglich machen angeblich aus
sicherheitsgründen allerdings sind in
den vergangenen tag auf von hier kommt
falls gefahr wirklich klick das eine
ausrede
opferrechte maststall infos auf kabul
verhindert das hilft jetzt nicht so
sondern auch andere kollegen bis 15 die
hier
paul ich wollte fragen wie viele
kollegen von von dir wie für
journalisten kollegen sind dort aus
welchen ländern bist du der einzige
deutsche vor ort
soweit ich das überblicke kennt bin ich
war der einzige deutschen vor
kollegen von bitdefender zb
wie sie von klein auf die fallweise an
wohin sie wollten aber müssen jetzt alle
oft war heute darf betrag
zusammen verlassen dass jahren sage der
amerikaner finanziert werde daher weiter
auf dem laufenden halten das ist
natürlich mit aller kraft abzusetzen
wollte das als erheblichen eingriff in
die pressefreiheit waren dem muss ich
sagen so vieles wichtiges zu beschreiben
gerade hier auf dem am rollfeld vor mir
nicht immer noch die luftwaffe der bund
nochmals
leider die übung abgebrochen vielen dank
für diese live eindrücke aus kabul vom
flughafen und wir versuchen dich
natürlich weiterhin gleich zu erreichen
dankeschön
[Musik]